our Millennials more prone to burn out
than other generations the answer is
maybe but not because they're
Millennials it's not some biological
thing that an entire generation is more
prone to burn out than a previous
generation I don't think that's it at
all but I think that the trend of how we
live our lives is very different I think
we are more solitary in how we live our
lives that there's good data that
there's fewer people there's fewer
marriages there's fewer people living
together people are staying single
longer and even the quality of
relationships which I've talked about
and others have talked about as well
where social media and cell phones
sometimes interrupt and get in the way
and brush straight our ability to form
those deep meaningful relationships
Millennials just by virtue of when they
were born and what technologies were
available that day were sort of on the
front line the first ones to grow up in
this in this world and these trends and
so I think that that the the opportunity
to ask for help or receive accept help
when it's offered that to express that
kind of vulnerability to deal with that
kind of stress I mean think about how
how easy it is when there's a conflict
with another human being it's just much
easier to ghost them than to have a
confrontation right you've been dating
somebody in for a while you really not
into it anymore instead of gaining
closure and like having a conversation
even a fight we just disappear why
because it's easier let's be honest but
I think that actually not only hurts the
other person actually creates loneliness
for us sometimes those those
confrontations even if they're difficult
are valuable I there's some good data on
this that somebody who gets ignored at
work there's like when their boss never
talks to them they never get any kind of
positive feedback never kind of negative
feedback I can be the exact numbers but
it's something like something like 7%
are engaged in their works it's
overwhelmingly high number of people are
disengaged simply because they get no
positive or negative feedback and if
they were get in trouble their level of
engagement actually goes up and if we
get one piece of positive feedback from
our bosses our level of engagement like
quadruples or something like that in
other words getting negative feedback
acts
make us more engaged in our work than
getting no feedback because at least
somebody knows we exist and that's the
point we I think one of the reasons that
this generation and maybe younger
generations and again not as a result of
them of the generation thing but rather
the the life in which they've grown up
just by virtue of when they grew up
probably does make them more prone to
burnout probably because they find
themselves doing more things themselves
that the concept of partnership or help
is is reduced so when you have more to
do when you have more in your plate you
have to be the breadwinner the homemaker
that all of this of course we're going
to burn out more
[Music]